alors ces derniers jours vous le savez
on reparle beaucoup de johnny évidemment
leur concert hommage stature nouvel
album et les fans sont toujours aussi
fou du chanteur moi je le comprends
aussi moi aussi et ça n'arrange pas tout
le monde parce que je l'espère vous
savez le nouveau compagnon de laëtitia
qui est un acteur réalisateur de talent
il en a fait les frais un an après
s'être mis en couple avec laeticia il ya
encore parfois critiquée même il a été
hué lors de la cérémonie mme 50 on a
découvert la statue la laisse pana
johnny hallyday que devant bercy il a
été hué un jour oui oui c'était assez
choquant et l'on regarde dès qu'ils ont
montré à la télé hier qu'il était à côté
de pas très loin de laëtitia lité
derrière sauf quand ils ont montré à la
télé y avait des grands écrans et du
coup les femmes ont eu vraiment ils ont
lavé le pauvre mois forcément il a voulu
leur répondre
du audio le clan hallyday c'est ce que
doivent se dire chaque matin le
réalisateur jalil lespert depuis qu'il
est en couple avec laeticia qui dans un
premier temps les deux amoureux avaient
fait le choix de la discrétion désormais
c'est sur tous les toits que les deux
artistes crient leur amour
relations pas toujours évidente nippo
joy et jade qui ont mis du temps à
accepter ce nouveau beau-père lui pour
les fans de johnny qui ont fui comme une
trahison cette nouvelle relation et qui
ont hué jalil lors de l'inauguration de
l'esplanade johnny hallyday cette
semaine aujourd'hui pour la toute
première fois jalil lespert a décidé de
se confier à paris match pour donner son
avis sur les critiques des fans du
taulier à son sujet je m'attendais à ce
genre de réaction c'est logique que
notre histoire at il une forme de
curiosité je me dis que ça passera avec
le temps mais pour lui le plus important
reste d'être heureux et épanoui dans sa
nouvelle vie de famille il devrait
comprendre que se reconstruire est
important pour laëtitia mais aussi pour
la tâche qu'elle a accompli reporter la
mémoire de cet artiste ce génie français
que l'on ne peut que respecter le
réalisateur profite également de cette
interview pour déclarer publiquement sa
flamme à laëtitia elle me plait pascal
hérard absolument unique jalil qui lui
met d'ailleurs des étoiles plein les
yeux puisqu'il a réalisé un de ses rêves
les plus chers jalil m'a aussi fait
découvrir le métro à 46 ans caché sous
un chapeau et un masque j'ai réalisé mon
rêve d'ado on imagine déjà ce que ça se
raconte et le découvrira le bus
non on avait un panneau devant gouès
qu'on est injuste pour jadida et ajuste
en fait c'est à cause d'elle ce bordel
parce qu'effectivement comme elle assume
pas forcément tous un jour elle est la
veuve de donner un jour elle est
amoureuse un jour à des aveux forcément
les gens ils sont perdus c'est normal
car en face sa vie et heureusement pour
elle elle est jeune elle est belle
jeannie d un mec formidable mais comme
elle elle joue à la fois la veuve
éplorée et à la fois l'amoureuse les
gens sont perdus et je comprends très
bien qu'ils soient agacés mais surtout
les files la femme d'affaires elle a
raison c'est un fardeau risa bête vous
avez pas entendu le pardon des finances
je donne entièrement raison et benjamin
as-tu fait tout ce qu il a dit allez
delphine
en fait les fans de johnny pu donc son
nouveau chéri comme si elle l'avait
trompé alors qu'en fait elle a aimé
johnny jusqu'au bout et il est mort mais
ça fait quand même quatre ans donc c'est
une femme voilà elle a besoin de l a
besoin de refaire sa vie donc en fait
c'est juste le compagnon qui accompagne
sa chérie actuelle il est il est là pour
la soutenir et donc c'est tout à fait
normal donc c'est très très injuste chez
les hommes je comprends pas c'est quoi
le message de ce qui eût jalil lespert
ça veut dire quoi elle a pas le droit de
refaire sa vie il n'a pas le droit de
l'accompagner sur ses déplacements en
fait j'aime le son que tout ce qui
tourne autour de laetitia et laetitia on
adore lui taper dessus gratuitement
enfin c'est honteux du lui jalil lespert
qui n'a rien à voir avec tout ça mais
qui sort de l'héritage avec johnny etc
on sait déjà que veut brûler constamment
gratuitement quand même un coup je
m'affiche demande un coup à jouer
mais très variables dans le nord mort ce
n'est pas vraiment ce qu'elle veut
mais quand c'est pas à lui ils n'ont pas
du tout chacun jeu de rôle par exemple
une déclaration quand même qui a surpris
beaucoup de monde c'est le coin oui
c'est une phrase stupide d'achille
gilles et ça c'est absurde oui mais ça
la fragilise ses croyances justement moi
je trouve que là tout à fait loi de se
reconstruire il faut pas sacraliser sa
vie passée comme si elle devait perdre
helmand respect dans le souvenir de
johnny elle peut revivre mais en faisant
ça en faisant ça je trouve que ls le
flanc aux attaques parce que c'est mais
bill de lire ça et cd même si c'est vrai
surtout ne le dit pas c'est pas de sa
faute sur johnny la pécho quand elle
était encore mineure n'a pas eu une vie
vraiment c'est avec une je n'y ai pas vu
des
débats mineurs
n'étaient pas mineures
il a pas brillé comme ça jean elle
ignore la bien le droit de prendre le
métro après sur le métro je vous trouve
un peu étonné la
partie comme ça
je vous trouve un peu dur sur nos métros
sur le métro bien évidemment qu'elle
n'avait jamais pris le métro à la peine
vie à prendre le métro c'était la femme
de johnny hallyday
vous vous y avez pas déjà
rexie tout agent
gines y prendre mais trois
noms mais
poster dans le métro il s'appelle
[Applaudissements]
vie comme la sienne on peut pas dire ça
comparé à toutes les personnes
effectivement qui prennent le soin c'est
un peu un côté de fausse modestie et
c'est le bâton
toujours étonné jeunesse et des montres
sont sortis aussi du contexte on sait
très bien que dans une interview ils
vont prendre la trace à la noix la
sortie
d'abord une forme de naïveté à l'adresse
comme ça laisse provincial moi moi je
suis prêt à l'oci dont elle salue paris
pour moi à l'époque quand je prenais le
métro parce que j'ai pris le bong dans
le métro bien seule et bien sûr qu'on
n'aime pas ça mais c'était la même
pratique ces deux
mois avec touches naïve à
l'éducation
comme ça résume bien votre oeil oui non
et bien je n'allais
elle devrait assumer pleinement son rôle
de femme d'affaires à l'habillement
patrimoine qu'elle doit faire fructifier
et c'est son rôle allait l'appeler là
pour ça voilà arrêté bien
doit jongler entre eux s la veuve de
johnny hallyday la grande star française
on a vu les obstacles et elle doit
jongler avec sa vie parce qu'elle doit
refaire sa mise
pour lui en fait je trouve qu'elle
annonce un peu trop savinel maintenant
voir les bonjour tout le monde
saulnier mais là ça y est on a peut-être
pas envie on sait qu'elle va refaire sa
vie et c'est très bien pour elle et elle
le mérite elle berg euros c'est parfait
mais est ce que vraiment on a envie de
voir ça est-ce que vous lui pour taper
vous abonner de
dire pourquoi ça ce couple là où par
exemple moi j'en avais discuté et nabila
et thomas pourquoi ils diffusent des
photos y compris de leurs enfants parce
que sinon ils sont traqués par les
paparazzi du coup
ils veulent maîtriser et quand les
photos sont parues aval moins cher pour
les paparazzis
l'argument est un peu facile à une fois
de plus moi je le donne raison à
benjamin merci
chaque année le magazine américain time
fait la liste des 100 personnalités les
plus influentes du monde et c'est à d
qui se sont le prince harry et mégane
qui font la une évidemment un ya un
français dans le classement est dominé
qui ces martyrs marcisz bien sûr
l'acteur français a cartonné cette année
dans le monde entier avec la série lupin
ne pas
lutter les plus influentes côté cinéma
en tout cas quand on voit ce nouveau
classement on se dit qu'il est loin le
temps où omar sy se déguisant odudu sur
canal+ pour amuser la ménagère à cette
dame et rendez-vous d'abidjan ouais
aujourd'hui dans acteurs français
notamment grâce au succès du film
intouchables omar sy et de paris à los
angeles un homme qui compte dans le
monde très sélect du septième art
et si en france il est très
régulièrement en bonne place dans le
classement du jdd des personnalités
préférées des français aux états unis
n'est pas en reste pour s'en rendre
compte il suffit d'ouvrir le nouveau
numéro du mythique magazine le times qui
compte marcy parmi les 100 personnalités
les plus influentes de 2021 et ce n'est
pas tout car dans l'article c'est le
comédien bradley cooper lui-même qui
intronise omar sy en louant ses mérites
notamment dans la série lui passe sur
netflix omar a tous les ingrédients et
les capacités pour faire ce qu'il veut
produire diriger et pour le faire avec
un coeur ouvert et généreux c'est ce
qu'on appelle la grande classe
[Musique]
par exemple l'année dernière dans la
catégorie politique il y avait à nidal
go je vous signale mais là ces
catégories cinéma alors est-ce que c'est
mérité selon vous non gilles ses avances
et pas catégorie cinéma globalement
c'est les personnes les plus influentes
et moi je suis très en colère je suis
très en colère par rapport à time
j'adore omar sy mais que les américains
où que tu ailles me considère comme ça
c'est de la condescendance et du mépris
je vais vous expliquer aux marques si
c'est un acteur formidable mais en quoi
est il influence us qui la js qu'il
interagit sur la vie des gens c'est ce
qu'on veut changer la vie des français
donc il nous méprise pour moi faire ça
c'est mépriser parce qu'il a fait lui
pas que ça marche vers la base élèves le
maintien au bar si génial mais non c'est
ni méritée pour lui et ça va être trop
dur à porter pour lui vraiment je
t'adore je t'aime beaucoup mais là tu
dis une énorme connerie parce que parce
que omar scié d'où les parti attrape
c'est plein de jeunes justement qui
décrivit l'influencé belle va peut-être
influencé peut-être même dix jeunes qui
part de zéro et qu'il se dise maintenant
il ya omar ça veut dire que quand on me
dit non toutes les deux minutes non tu
ne travailleras pas ce poste là non tu
ne feras pas de cinéma non tu ne seras
pas footballeurs et ben je vais le faire
quand même parce qu'il ya des mecs les
servir et carrément certaines connues
samedi à metz il ya des métis envers ces
personnes les plus influentes de tram
c'est tout le monde
déclare sans mon quart des 100 personnes
par rapport à sa carrière au vu de sa
carrière au vu des gens qui vont le voir
au cinéma 1re es au vu de la starks l
influence qu on trouve aussi des parts
avait vu passer son message et ont même
s'ils ont fait ça
c'est pas les gens michel on peut me
bélanger en adéquation avec ses idées
etc on peut ne pas aimer ses films mais
c'est un fait est qu'aujourd'hui à
chaque fois ou du mois presque à chaque
fois ces films font un carton jaune
à chaque fois qu'ils donnent ses
opinions politiques il est suivi
serré sur une plate forme a été la plus
triste moi je trouve ça très bien que
marseille soit par contre suis déçu
qu'un seul français on a plein de
français qui rayonne dans des sportifs
des acteurs bah je sais pas dj snake des
joueurs de foot des gens qui sont connus
mondialement les daft punk des grands
chefs cuisiniers etc cet hommage qui est
que omar sy on est bien sur les ondes et
casques et ensuite pardon est-ce que
plasma plusieurs états ce classement je
les regardais c'est n'importe quoi il ya
des acteurs qui jouent dans des films
d'auteur que personne regarde où son
kanye west et drake parents qui sont les
plus gros vendeurs de disques oui kim
kardashian qui est quand même la plus
grande influence us du monde c'est une
personnalité qui compte aujourd'hui sur
la scène médiatique sonne avec lui je
crois que quatre essais tous âges et
sexes venus sur voilà il ya
assez de l'entre- soit et c'est pas un
classement qui est exhaustive c'est nul
c'est n'importait pas si c'est de
l'entretoit moi je suis fier coma il
serait dans
l'entreprise c'est super
c'est pas fini bernard on va arrêter de
laisser bien des métiers d'arts ménagers
mais il avait deux films dans l'année
qui marque en amérique il vit en
amérique oui c'est un des rares c'est un
des rares français qui il a dérobé
elie pas s'y attendait parce qu'il dit
n'importe quoi il a été numéro 1 sur la
plateforme voyons je sais plus combien
cette question
et encore si l'affluence que nui son nom
aujourd'hui il a une influence sur le
monde du cinéma mais sur le monde et si
on peut monter c'est pas un messie
série l'affluence plus la société
française que le collège seront chères
d'accord avec toi c'est
pas une bonne chose d'abord à commencer
pour remercier lui même parce que je
trouve c'était un vrai simple c'est en
train de devenir un faux simple qui vit
dans le quartier ultra rue panne d état
nauséeux
c'est ainsi parce que maintenant du coup
il ouvre beaucoup et c'était mieux qu'il
ouvrait même temps
élu pas pardon on a aussi le droit de
dire que ce n'est pas une aussi bonne
série oui mais regardez hier 54 millions
nador mais dans les choix qu'on vient
des dons ont été influencés et la
passion et mes amis au revoir ses
téléspectateurs il ya un sondage voilà
alors massip y en avait pas de féculents
dans sa vérité 54 ans à y regarder entre
art et voulait partir
mais parce qu'ils sont partis de la city
ben on partait de rien avec personne et
servir à autre
chose ça fait maintenant plusieurs
semaines que les parisiens n'en
reviennent pas lionel messi c'est une
des plus grandes stars de l'histoire du
foot ah bah ouais bah elle est au psg
c'est magnifique alors depuis cinq
bonnes infos bernard
[Applaudissements]
de manioc s'envole sa vieille salle dit
oui voilà il continue de construire son
empire financier à paris ils cherchent
maintenant où habitait évidemment il va
pas habiter dans un petit studio à
regarder
[Musique]
en ce moment quand on parle football on
parle surtout du transfert de l'année
l'arrivée de lionel messi au pg une
arrivée d'un des meilleurs joueurs au
monde qui fait aujourd'hui autant parler
pour son jeu de jambes que pour son
compte en banque
le paris saint germain a dû casser sa
tirelire plus de 40 millions d'euros de
salaire net annuel il faut dire que les
footballeurs sont parmi les
personnalités les mieux payés au monde
alors forcément avec un tel transfert
les chiffres atteignent des sommets et
qui dit déménagement d'une nouvelle
maison s'installer paisiblement à paris
messi et les siens auraient des vues sur
une villa pour la - cosy une petite
merveille qui coûterait la bagatelle de
48 millions d'euros il faut dire qu'on
parle d'un palais situé dans le vésinet
à côté de paris de 2000 m² pour le
logement principal est de 500 mètres
carrés supplémentaires pour accueillir
les proches dans la guest house et
soyons honnêtes le nail a de quoi voir
venir avec son arrivée au psg le joueur
argentin toucherait cent treize mille
euros par jour soit un salaire mensuel
de 3 4 millions d'euros net avec un
contrat de deux ans plus une année
optionnelle il y à fort à parier que
l'agent immobilier devrait accepter son
dossier sans rechigner
non monsieur avant-bras donkey la châtre
à jamais
ag il est choqué oui quand même parce
que les sommes sont folles alors je
voudrais juste vous donner une info sur
la manière dont les footballeurs
étrangers comme messi négocié leurs
salaires en france près quand on dit
n'être c'est double nettes c'est à dire
que c'est le net social on enlève les
charges et le net fiscal ils sont
terrorisés par le fisc en france les
équipes du psg calcule combien les
avions vont alors prendre et messi et
dit moi je me moque totalement de vos
impôts je veux savoir combien j'aurais
dans la poche à la fin de la saison et
donc le salaire brut et monumental et
moi quand je vois le palais
hypersécurisée luxueux là au jour
d'aujourd'hui je sais que ça peut
paraître démagogique mais oui ça me
choque c'est amusant un fabuleux logique
c'est démago
franchement
une beuverie évidemment une maison à 48
millions d'euros c'est énorme et c'est
en phase avec ses revenus il est
milliardaire mais s'il fait partie des
rares sportifs qui sont milliardaires à
barcelone y avait une plus petite villa
qu'il avait acheté 2 millions d'euros
qui en vaut 10 millions aujourd'hui là
c'est en phase avec ses revenus en
attendant il était logé dans une suite
d'un grand hôtel à 17000 euros la nuit
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui compte
maintenant choquant par exemple ben non
ça c'est le groupe est détenu par le psg
c'est le groupe hôtelier faty sponsors
qui seront de ceaurriz le psg donc c'est
des chambres des médias tu as raison un
tarif préférentiel mais voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui de toute façon est
complètement hors sol donc c'est plus
rien de choquant pour messi est dans la
bagarre fait normal et donc elle a mal
joué hier parce qu'il s'adaptait way
qu'elle est méchante elle
en fait il rapporte beaucoup donc et
gagner beaucoup et tant mieux s'ils le
dépensent a fait tourner l'économie s'il
y avait quelqu'un de tellement riche qui
ne dépensait pas eh bien personne n'en
profiterai donc
y'a qu'en franchement chercheurs car aux
états unis un sportif qui aime beaucoup
ça choquera personne qu'il est une benne
a raison mais c'est pas parce que la
population est
bah non il ya des pauvres aussi
mais beaucoup plus importante donc les
enjeux sont plus importants et les
cachets des publicitaires sont pas
beaucoup mais
si regardez les chiffres de mai 6 et 7
c'est d'aller voir senna va arriver
normalement ça y est abaissée la wiwi
celle à 38 millions reversés la sécurité
c'est pas mal hein 10 millions reversés
trésor public mais c'est bien ça il fait
gagner 50 millions à l'état français bah
oui c'est évidemment des maillots ils
génèrent va les regarder la vente des
maillots il dépasse plus de 50 % celle
de neymar ah oui ça c'est marrant ça va
quand même et il a fait augmenter de 20%
les abonnements sur les réseaux sociaux
du club je le lis parce que certains
estiment sa fin
je te le faire d'accord mais ronaldo qui
fait exploser davantage que messi les
réseaux sociaux quand tes posts un
message ou quand ils signent quelque
part voilà c'est les deux joueurs ils
sont les plus grandes stars actuelles
est vrai qu'on revoie les salaires la
coque vous avez montré la vie tu fais
parce que vous avez montré la juste
avant ces énormes regardant mes
s'effacer par céder ça c'est pas des
salaires c'est les revenus avec les
revenus publicitaires avec les salaires
+ primes + publicité c'est son sourire
c'est de salaire pour le sponsoring
quand on parle de la bulle spéculative
justement sur les salaires des
footballeurs sachant que les français
finalement parce qu'effectivement ira il
rapporte énormément d'argent au moins ça
mais c'est normal ce qu'on a envie de
voir je sais pas moi bernard arnault
françois pinault vivre dans un studio de
40 m² bas donc voilà ma lui vie donnée
au vésinet à me dans sa piscine c'est
très bien comme ça en tout cas
d'augmenter de 20% les abonnés les
réseaux sociaux mon club c'est important
aussi pour eux et bien moi je moi je
suis pas vraiment choqué les lacets des
sommes astronomiques évidemment c'est
loin et c'est un rêve et c'est là je
mets moi j'ai mis non parce que comme on
a parlé de l'imposition 50 millions ça
va nous servir à nous tous ça sert aux
écoles ça sert aux hôpitaux ça sert à
fonctionner voilà cinquante c'est pour
ça que je dis pourquoi t'es pas choquer
avec l'argent du football parce que
l'argent du football français c'est
l'argent qui est sur le territoire
français ça reste sur le territoire
français après quand je vois tous les
chiffres et que je compare à la vie des
gens de tous les jours dans toute une
vie tu vas gagner 700 wii 6000 euros bah
oui mais est obligé de comparer quand tu
vois tu sens que tu vas bosser le matin
tu vois 126 millions tu dis moi toute ma
vie je vais rentrer 800000 euros
d'amendé quarante ans lot d'objets de
comparer le dis tu te dis plutôt que
d'acheter des fois des bagnoles plutôt
tacher démontre pourquoi il aiderait pas
envie
de charité au
montant que vous voyez là on n'entend
pas la caisse de résonance qu'on devrait
entendre par ses voisins où les mecs 126
millions 117 millions mais je suis zen
raymond les premiers à ce point c'est
les premiers à acheter des places pour
aller voir le football mais parce que
c'est une passion faut bien survivre
rester chez toi qu'il allait aller c'est
comme un conte chez apple est une
passion ceci dit c'est grâce à mes
abonnements mais oui comme un gout mes
abonnements jeu 80 euros pour le
football mois en abonnement télécom un
canard quand je vais au foot quand je
vais aux matches près 40 balle comme un
connard outrance badge achètent des pop
corns est une bière
je participe à ça mais je me dis c'est
pas grave c'est une passion la passion
il faut avoir des patients dans la vie
mais quand tu vois les montants tu te
dis toute ta vie tu va brasser 700 bien
oui mais c'est déjà pas mal que d'aimer
les gens te fasse rêver des mecs wii
est très généreux ouais mama pays donne
à son club formateur il donne il est il
et il est impliqué dans le social
vraiment ça c'est ce que je suis pas
gêné sur l'immobilier mais les montres à
sais pas combien 200000 euros les
voitures à 30 millions d'euros est ce
que regardent ils ont mieux
[Rires]
non mais c'est vrai mais quand tu gagne
autant d'argent tu tâche mais moi mais
moi je veux dire alors on ferme tout le
monde vous dit les démagos regarde moi
je te dis si moi je prenais 126 millions
de 117 millions j'allume la radio et je
me dis ça c'est très démago et en
afrique il ya des gens qui crèvent de
faim et qu'il ya des gens qui meurent je
serai pas bien bon je serai pas que je
pourrais pas me regarder dans la glace
en me disant 126 millions d'euros est
aidé en afrique y en a qui compte
on
ferait pas bienvenue dit mais on ne sait
pas si
je m'occupe de nombreuses associations
j'anime souvent des soirées mais suis
d'accord mais tu donnes d'orb et je
donne
je donne de ma personne et
d'un camp fait que ces mecs là sont pas
de chasse justifie
justifie pas mais quand on leur demande
de justifier c'est quand même bien long
mais nous voulons qu'ils vont devenir
des salaires dans le monde aujourd'hui
dans le monde de souffrance
d'aujourd'hui tout le monde on est aussi
des réalités décembre comme ça vous
choque
chanteur alors pour les acteurs
regardent on a parlé du concert de
johnny hallyday radio 1 c'est celui rafa
concert c'est mon fils était formidable
france 2 a donné six cent mille euros et
le concert il a rapporté 500 mille euros
pour des associations ça sans me
l'aurait s'est fait chier pour sa cent
mille euros c'est des pourboires pour
500 millions pour réseau
dans ce procédé pour boire ça sent les
avirons